pasamos a nuestra revista de prensa en
directo América con Rosa Pérez mateu
Rosa Un saludo para usted Buenos días
Ángela bueno tenemos una noticia bien
grande esta mañana el medio
especializado en cuestiones laborales
llamado World perfect Union hace un
balance del accidente de tren en Ohio en
el que se descarriló un ferrocarril
provocado un provocando Perdón un
vertido de materiales tóxicos cuéntenos
sobre la noticia efectivamente no Y para
poner un poco a nuestra audiencia en
contexto empezamos con el párrafo que
abre este artículo para situarnos Y es
que el tres de febrero de 2023 un tren
de carga de la compañía
en una catástrofe ambiental que ilustra
como los derechos de los trabajadores la
explotación empresarial y los
ecosistemas están estrechamente
conectados porque dice este medio que
están conectados bien porque este
ferrocarril contaba con 150 vagones de
los cuales 20 transportaban materiales
tóxicos y tras el descarrilamiento
ardieron durante días no por un lado
ardieron por el propio choque pero
también porque las fuerzas de emergencia
quemaron parte de esto sea materiales
para llevar a cabo una Liberación
controlada no los residentes de hispales
de esta localidad donde tuvo lugar el
incidente son unas 5000 personas y ya
recientemente esta semana han sido
avisadas por las autoridades de que
pueden regresar a sus casas sin embargo
muchos de ellos denuncian a tener dolor
de cabeza náuseas que las mascotas el
ganado o la vida Silvestre del lugar
están enfermos o muertos Y es que los
productos químicos también se vertieron
sobre la cuenca del Río Ohio que de la
que se abastecen unos 5 millones de
personas según nos cuenta este artículo
y algunos vecinos señalan que se van por
siempre no para siempre por el temor ya
de la contaminación de las aguas de su
tierra del ambiente bien pero a todo
esto los trabajadores ferroviarios y a
los expertos No señalaban desde hace
tiempo que la situación era una bomba de
relojería bueno responsable que estas
cosas todavía hoy nos estén pasando y
vamos a ver porque usted habla de esta
bomba de relojería con el artículo de
The Hill que plantea cinco preguntas
todavía sin respuestas sobre este
accidente Cuáles son Exactamente no en
primer lugar qué había dentro de estos a
20 vagones con productos peligrosos
cinco de los cuales con cloruro de
vinilo no que es una químico explosivo y
cancerígeno que se utiliza para fabricar
plástico duro y que ante el riesgo de
que este producto generará una explosión
como decimos las autoridades llevaron a
cabo una quema controlada lo que está
combustión dio lugar a gas fosfeno queda
una gas que se utilizaba como arma
química en la Primera Guerra Mundial no
bien había otras sustancias tóxicas para
el organismo como disolventes
industriales y todo esto sin que este
tren esté convoy estuviera catalogado
como inflamable de alto peligro no bueno
por otro lado como decíamos no los
expertos a de seguridad desde hace
tiempo señalaban que la situación
ferroviaria en Estados Unidos es
peligrosa para una falta de regulaciones
entonces este medio de Gil se plantea
por qué estas ausencia de regulaciones
no y señala que uno de los temas que
genera más controversia es alrededor de
la cuestión de los frenos de un cambio
de frenos y señala Que norfolk souther
formó parte de la coalición de compañías
ferroviarias que lucharon con éxito
contra esta regulaciones no de cambiar
de un tipo de frenos que frena una rueda
tras otra con un freno eléctrico que las
frena a todas de golpe y señala que bien
no que
northen junto con otras compañías
consiguieron un indulto de la
Administración Obama y luego una
derogación por parte de la
Administración Trump lo más inquietante
es ver que todo esto podría volver a
ocurrir y así lo precisa también el ius
a today que señala que son cada vez más
inseguros así como decía el artículo
anterior efectivamente no señala este
artículo que ya ha habido
parecidas de magnitudes similares y que
esta empresa junto con otras han evitado
cada vez Pues que se establecieran más
regulaciones Y qué es lo que está
pasando bien que para reducir costos
para que las empresas sean
económicamente más productivas norcen
por ejemplo despidió al 40% de su
personal desde 2015 y por ejemplo lo que
señala recrean quienes portavoz del
sindicato de transportes de los
trabajadores ferroviarios lo que
perciben a los trabajadores es una gran
presión para moverse lo más rápido
posible y generar la mayor cantidad de
ganancias posible esto con trenes cada
vez más largos y cada vez más pesados
porque no hay una limitación a la
longitud no de los trenes por parte de
la Administración Federal solo para que
nos acabamos de hacer una idea este tren
de 150 vagones y medía aproximadamente
unas dos millas lo que serían unos tres
kilómetros no Cuál es la elección Para
cerrar con este tema nos dice el
vehículo al que hacíamos referencia
cuando un tren descarrila y vemos
inmensas bolas de fuego en el cielo
sobre Ohio no se trata de un accidente
extraño se trata de un problema
sistémico con lucrativas compañías
ferroviarias que anteponen las ganancias
a las personas y rápidamente porque ya
nos quedamos sin tiempo en Estados
Unidos ya está la candidatura de la
republicana Nicky hayley a las primarias
republicanas efectivamente Y un medio
conservador como es National review
señalan que temen que la candidatura de
Nicky hayley sea puramente vanidad y que
nos sirva ningún buen propósito no
finalmente dicen que temen que ayude a
ensalzar a Trump no dice las primeras
encuestas indican que existe un riesgo
real de que hailey sea el tipo de
candidata que no lo hace suficientemente
bien como para competir por la
nominación pero sí como para ayudar a
dividir la votación y poner a Trump En
la cima ven Ángela veremos lo que acaba
pasando y sin duda no esta relación tan
intermitente entre highlight y Trump una
de las cuestiones más destacadas en la
prensa desde que se conoció ayer la
nominación
porque esto se parece mucho se parece
mucho y más que se parecerá sin duda
Bueno pues muchas gracias a usted Rosa